back in june jack dorsey who is a noted
bitcoin bull runs both twitter and
square
uh had a whole tweet storm and this
specific tweet
he said if matt get pulled up so that i
can read it
he said that uh square was considering
making a hardware wallet for bitcoin if
they do it they'd build it entirely in
the open from software to hardware
design
and in collaboration with the community
and they want to kick off this thinking
the right way by sharing some of their
guiding principles they went on this
whole tweet thread
and he explained it this is june 4th
well we just got an update
last week and jack came out with another
kind of tweet storm
uh and he said the following which was
square is creating a new business so
kind of a subsidiary at square
and it is going to uh i believe
uh be not combined with but be another
subsidiary so
square seller squares cash app title
those are all subsidiaries underneath
square
i believe this new business uh is just
alongside them
it's gonna be focused on building an
open developer platform
with the sole goal of making it easy to
create
non-custodial permissionless and
decentralized financial services
primary focus is on bitcoin and the name
was
tbd now for those keeping track at home
tbd is not the name that stands for
to be determined not yet determined uh
and so this is fascinating to me because
when you look at what he's talking about
here there's a couple of things
one is he's specifically saying that
they're going to build an
open developer platform so the idea here
is not for
square to build a centralized service
and then to say
hey we square know the answers and we're
going to then
force you the user to use our product
and we own centralized control and
therefore
you're giving up on the ethos of bitcoin
uh instead what they said is we're going
to build a platform
that provides these developer tools
to individual developers that allows
them
to more easily create non-custodial
permissionless and decentralized
financial services
so the whole idea is taking d5
decentralized finance
and bringing it to bitcoin and square
saying you know what
we sit in a very unique position where
we have great technical talent we have
access to capital and we've got the ear
of the community we're going to build a
bunch of developer tools we're going to
hand those to developers
and we hope that by giving them
basically the picks and shovels
they're then going to leverage those to
go build amazing things that focus on
non-custodial permissionless and
decentralized financial services
to me this might be one of the most
exciting things i've seen in bitcoin in
a long time right
yeah this is great why one
jack is a beast of his own and the
companies he's build and continues to
build like
he's very obviously very stretched in
the time and the limits he has does he
go
is he the goat right now now that bezos
got so rich that he retired
we're talking active now yeah yeah
active like if this was sports and we
stack ranked him is jack dorsey the goat
at the moment he's a future hall of
famer for sure
tom brady jack dorsey is definitely a
future hall of famer but is he the
greatest of all time right now
sure yeah who else who musk i guess goes
up there
yeah musk is up there and we're not
counting bezos because he retired yeah
he retired he got so
uh jerome powell made him so rich that
they forced him into retirement
in flight gate i'm just saying looking
flake gate that's why bazel's retired he
got so rich that he had to retire we'll
have to do a segment once where we do
the mount rushmore should we do mount
rushmore or uh
maybe we should create a hall of fame
and just literally put up the pictures
of all of the hall of fame
entrepreneurs yeah but determined by us
in the best business show research team
that's what we're gonna do all right so
keep going john you said that he's a
beast of his own
yeah he's a beast of his own he's
clearly creating a lot of different
companies he's very into bitcoin which
is great
but it's just it's nice to see what
markets he in and
he is in and how he's thinking about um
about decentralized finance and
how he wants square to get involved in
that well he's going to make bitcoin
custody more mainstream right and that's
what it comes down to is they're
instantly going to be the biggest player
in that space
from just their market and name
recognition outside of what they've done
in crypto and other other categories
he's already made
uh pretty big avenues in cash app and
some of the other kind of financial
applications he's built
but when it comes to square they'll
instantly be the biggest player and it's
really all about just making it
mainstream which will help
a lot with adoption in my stan in my
opinion uh
cash app essentially all of the profit
from the last quarter's numbers that i
remember i think it was last quarter
came from bitcoin like the buying and
selling of bitcoin on cash app
was almost exclusively from bitcoin uh
or the revenue was from bitcoin or
profit
and so when you start to think about how
instrumental bitcoin has been to square
as a business already
it makes sense that he realizes over the
next 20 years if you're a long-term
thinker
bitcoin is going to become a bigger and
bigger
portion of the financial system and if
you can
be a core piece of infrastructure in
that system
then you will likely reap the financial
benefits and your business will continue
to grow for
you know years to come and so i think
that's part of what's so fascinating
about what jack understands here
is that he is frankly just ahead of the
curve he's recognizing a kind of a
market trend
and he's figuring out ways to marry what
most people would think is pretty
difficult
the expectations of wall street and kind
of the pressures
of building a large financial
institution in a
regulated public market with the ethos
of
bitcoin and being able to speak to both
groups at the same time
use technology and not piss off the
bitcoin community and do things that
they would seem as kind of violating
uh their view of the world but at the
same time uh appeasing to some degree
the corporate investor uh kind of
corporate world or the wall street
investor and that to me is like
the the tightrope act that he's walking
and why you have to take a guy like that
and put him
at or near the top of the kind of best
operating entrepreneurs right now
is because that is very very very
difficult to do
and that's all the work you have to do
before you even start building the
products then you got to execute you got
to market you got to acquire users you
got to do all the things that are
necessary just to build a great business
he's actually doing a ton of work up
front because of the complexity and the
nuance here
between the bitcoin community and the
corporate world who frankly
hate each other don't like each other
they yell and scream at each other all
day long and they couldn't have
different ideals
uh kind of eat those and views of where
the world's going right so i got the
numbers
which is on cash app and bitcoin so are
you wait
hold on are you head of the best
business show research team now
today i am today i'll take john usually
is quick with the
john's usually the head of the uh best
business
research team perfect the co-heads um
okay so square these numbers are from
february so it was the earnings report
before the last
but essentially it says that they they
made 4.57 billion
in bitcoin revenue last year so that was
97 million dollars of gross profit
and that was up almost 800 percent year
over year
and then out of that uh they said that
that represented almost
48 of their total revenue last year so
bitcoin transactions the
the money they made off of selling
bitcoin on cash app made 50
made up 50 of their revenue and 85 of
revenue gains last year
so it was their biggest revenue driver
by far over the last year
i mean those are some crazy numbers yeah
right the the thing that
also i think is uh very telling so this
is a guy who
uh we if we just do like a jack check
real quick
he's built two multi-billion dollar
businesses i don't know what squares
market cap is right now but i think it's
you know 2025
or i'm sorry uh twitter's market cap is
like 20 25 billion square
uh was 100 billion probably probably
more than that um and so if you look at
that he's
created like let's call it somewhere
over a hundred billion dollars of total
market cap value across two companies he
runs both of them
uh he's done by all intents and uh
measurements
um a pretty good job there's plenty of
people who've got complaints
uh specifically around censorship on a
platform which he
openly says he doesn't want to have that
responsibility they kind of got thrust
into the light
there's plenty of people who think
twitter should be making more money all
kinds of complaints but for
uh the role that he sits in he has done
from my view
a very good job um and built a lot of
shareholder value
and now he's basically saying i see an
opportunity
for permissionless decentralized
financial services
that is built around bitcoin which if
you know me if you've been listening to
the podcast if you've been paying
attention to what i tweet i've said over
and over and over again the most
mispriced opportunity in the market in
my opinion
is decentralized financial services
built on top of bitcoin it looks like
jack agrees and they're going to go full
fledged into this and if he's successful
here and he's able to build
a platform that hands these tools to
developers
the amount of economic kind of uh value
creation
that occurs is going to be absolutely
off the charts
and the beauty of it is some of that
will flow to square and kind of their
financial
balance sheet but some of it won't some
of it will just empower other people to
be successful
and i think that that's what some of the
fun here is he's empowering other people
to be successful as well